hi everyone today let's talk about
terraform versus ansible
now in some of our videos past we've
talked about terraform in detail
ansible and even infrastructure as code
but i think a lot of you might be
wondering when to use terraform
and when to use ansible and in my view
these are actually two very
complementary tools
so i believe you can use them together
when you're doing kind of your
infrastructure automation
now i think the first thing people think
about when they think about
infrastructure automation is
actually the step of provisioning right
so how do we actually get
something up and running so that we can
actually start you know
doing our application development and
that kind of thing that's one thing
terraform is really good at
and one of the reasons it's so good at
it is because terraform is declarative
in nature and this is actually one of
the key differences between terraform
and ansible
but we'll get to that in a minute so
let's see what a kind of a terraform
configuration would look like
so we want to provision some resources
let's say on a public cloud
we're going to do so in a declarative
way so we'll start by saying maybe we
want a database service
so we'll say create db and they'll have
some configuration to go with it like
you know what kind of class it is and
what size that kind of thing
maybe we also want to create a
kubernetes cluster
and maybe even some vms
in a vpc so we'll first create the vpc
and maybe some more configuration to
create the vms
so we'll kind of have our terraform
config there
now i mentioned it's declarative and
this is awesome because you know
in these steps over here we've created
some db services and some other things
so let's say we want to actually bind
that database service to our kubernetes
cluster
so in in this step right here we'll say
bind
to kubernetes now in a procedural
language
everything would go top to bottom so it
would start with the db and realize hey
i can't bind it to something that
doesn't exist
but since terraform is declarative it'll
actually say okay we can't do this one
yet
let's create the kubernetes cluster
first also create the vpc cluster
kind of simultaneously and then once
that's ready
then we'll create the database because
it's dependent on the kubernetes cluster
to bind to
this is essentially what's called an
implicit dependency you can also do
explicit dependencies where you
can just tell a resource to wait until
another one is
up and ready to go so that's one of the
key advantages of terraform
is that it takes kind of a declarative
approach
so we've talked about terraform let's
kind of switch gears here a little bit
and talk about what ansible is really
good at
and now ansible's main kind of purpose
in my opinion
is configuration management this
includes things like application
deployment
but it can actually also do
infrastructure provisioning
now one of the key things i'll say about
ansible is that it's not necessarily
declarative
but it supports declarative resources
and it's not necessarily procedural
either it's kind of
let's call it a hybrid
now in this sense i basically mean that
you know ansible
supports much like terraform kind of
configuration files to do your
automation
so for example configuration management
task can be something like
first you would start up a vm maybe it
was stopped
maybe you need to restart it or stop it
or something like that and some
configuration so
just telling it you know just to start
up then maybe you install some
application
into the vm and some drivers maybe you
need to install the runtimes
and so you kind of have some
configuration steps maybe you utilize
the open source community where they
you know build modules and collections
of these things that make you
allow you to get started quickly and
then maybe finally you start the actual
application so these are all config
management tasks app
application deployment you're working
with resources that are already created
now the reason i say it's hybrid is
because although the resources are
written kind of in a declarative fashion
they're actually executed top to bottom
so this is an ansible playbook
and ansible with first star with the vm
creation and then installing the app and
then starting the app
so if you had these in the wrong order
things wouldn't work correctly so that's
my view that's why i think you know
ansible is declarative and procedural in
a sense it's kind of a hybrid of both
depending on how your modules are
written
so we've got our infrastructure we've
got our kind of configuration
now let's talk about you know going back
to terraform what it looks like to
actually
start executing this configuration so
first thing we'll do
is you know generally you want to do
something called a terraform plan which
will enable you to see
what will actually come up before you
actually execute
the real api calls we'll do a terraform
plan and
you know it'll spin up some of this a
view of
what's going to actually get created so
the database cluster the vpc
and when it all looks good you'll do a
terraform apply that will use your api
key and run the actual
api calls against your cloud provider
you know using your api key
and spin up all of that infrastructure
and this is what terraform is really
good at and this brings me to
my third thing about terraform is that
it's very much managed on state
for life cycle management so one of the
really cool things here is for example
you know once you've created this
infrastructure if you go back
and you know remove an entire piece of
config
for example to create vpc block if you
remove that and you run a terraform
apply again
it'll actually remember from last time
it'll say hey last time you had this now
you've removed it and it'll go ahead and
remove that vpc
for you now the difference with ansible
is that there is no kind of
life cycle management
no now essentially what this means is
that if you wanted to delete
some step of this flow you can't just
remove it you would need to kind of mark
it for deletion so you
need to kind of do a remove app step now
that's that doesn't go
to say that you couldn't necessarily
create an ansible playbook
that automatically recognizes when you
remove some configuration and run the
steps
the point is with terraform you get it
automatically and with ansible you kind
of have to
implement that life cycle management
into your actual code
another key point i want to make here is
item potency
so that's essentially the ability to run
something multiple times and if nothing
has changed it won't actually run
anything
run any new actions so with terraform
you get that automatically so you can
run this a thousand times
and the first time it'll create
everything and the remaining 999 times
it would actually just say hey you
already have it nothing's changed
and it wouldn't do anything now with
ansible
you could technically create item potent
modules but it's not a requirement
so that's something that you as a
developer have to consider when using
ansible is you know
see the community modules you're using
the cloud provider modules and
collections you're using
and make sure they're important and if
they're not you know you might have to
do some additional work
to get them going now i think i've made
a case for both capabilities here
but i want to talk a little bit about
the similarities between the two as well
for one they both support heavy
templating
so this is great so you can have kind of
one source of truth and then different
configuration files so for example if
you wanted a dev
and a test and a prod environment you
can have one source of truth
and then kind of just switch out the
variables that you're using to spin up
the different environments
so that's something neat that both
environments support number two
they're both open source as i mentioned
but the key thing i want to mention is
that you know they've got a big kind of
community as well
so for terraform they have the terraform
registry with modules being developed
providers to work with the cloud
providers and and so they've got this
rich community to help you get started
very quickly and ansible's the same
they've got ansible galaxy with
collections of modules so you can get
started very quickly with existing
playbooks and that kind of thing
so they're they're similar in that sense
that they've got this big kind of
community
and the last thing i'll say is agent
lists which is kind of more
relevant in the ansible context than
terraform since they're it's doing
configuration management
you don't have to install an agent on a
vm somewhere it's
both of these tools are kind of plug and
play easy to get started whether on your
local machine
or somewhere in the cloud these tools
are both very similar in that they're
easy and quick to get started with
now you might be wondering you know in
the beginning i said these tools are
complementary
so how would you use ansible and
terraform together
well there's a couple of approaches you
could start with terraform
now as i mentioned terraform is really
good at provisioning so you could have a
terraform configuration that spins up
some infrastructure
and then once that infrastructure is
ready you can actually use terraform to
call ansible
to do configuration management on the on
the resources you spun up
so starting the vm and installing an app
and that kind of thing
you could also take the other approach
and start with ansible and in the first
step of your ansible playbook
call terraform to spin up infrastructure
and then pick up where terraform leaves
off take that infrastructure which is
you know
in some inventory an ansible inventory
and run the ansible actions on that
so in essence ansible and terraform can
work really well together because
terraform is very good
at infrastructure provisioning but falls
short where ansible comes in
with configuration management and i
think together
you know both open source world-class
infrastructure automation tools i think
together you can really create a
complete
infrastructure automation story i want
to thank you for joining me for this
video today
if you want to see what ibm cloud is
doing in the infrastructure automation
space
be sure to check out ibm cloud
schematics if you have any questions or
you like the video be sure to drop a
comment below
and a like be sure to subscribe and stay
tuned for more videos like this in the
future
thank you